you have this amazing paper you
co-authored a survey paper called
emergent abilities of large language
models
has again the philosophy here that i'd
love to ask you about
what's the intuition about the phenomena
of emergence in neural networks
transformers language models
is there a magic
threshold beyond which we start to see
certain performance
and is that different from task to task
is that us humans just being poetic and
romantic or is there literally some
level at which we start to see
breakthrough performance
yeah i mean this is a property that we
start seeing
um in systems that actually
tend to be
so in machine learning traditionally
again going to benchmarks i mean if if
you have a some input outputs right like
that is just a single input and a single
output you generally
when you train these systems you see
reasonably smooth
curves when you analyze how
how much the data
set size affects the performance or how
the model size affect the performance or
how much you long train you how how long
you train the system for uh affects the
performance right so
you know if we think of image net like
the training curves look fairly smooth
and predictable in a way
and
i would say that's probably because of
the it's kind of a one
a one hop
reasoning task right it's like here is
an input and you think for a few
milliseconds or 100 milliseconds 300 as
a human and then you tell me yeah
there's
there's an alpaca in this image
so
in language
we are seeing benchmarks that require
more pondering and more
thought in a way right this is just kind
of you you you need to look for some
subtleties
that it involves
inputs that you you might think of or if
even if the input is a sentence
describing a mathematical problem
there is there is a bit more processing
required as a human and more
introspection so
i think the
how these benchmarks work
means that there is actually a threshold
um
just going back to how transformers work
in this way of querying for the right
questions to get the right answers that
might mean that performance becomes
random
until the right question is asked by the
querying system of a transformer or of a
language model like a transformer
and then
only only then you might start seeing
performance going from random to
non-random and
this is more empirical there's there's
no formalism or or theory behind this
yet although it might be quite important
but
we're seeing these phase transitions of
random performance and until some let's
say scale of a model and then it goes
beyond that and it might be that
you need to fit
a few
low order bits of thought
before you can make progress on the
whole task and if you could measure
actually
those breakdown of the task maybe you
would see more smooth oh like yeah these
you know once once you get these and
these and these and this and these then
you start making progress in the task
but it's somehow um a bit annoying
because then
it means that certain
questions we might ask about
architectures um possibly cannot only be
done at certain scale and
one thing that um conversely i've seen
great progress on in the last couple
years is this notion of science of deep
learning and science of scale in
particular right so
on the negative is that there's some
benchmarks for which progress
might need to be measured at at minimum
at certain scale until you see then what
details of the model matter to make that
performance better right so that's a bit
of a con but
what we've also seen is that you can
you can sort of empirically analyze
behavior of models at scales that are
smaller right so let's say to put an
example um we had this chinchilla paper
that revised the so-called scaling laws
of models and that whole study is done
at a reasonably small scale right that
maybe hundreds of millions up to one
billion parameters and then the cool
thing is that you create some loss right
some loss that some trends right you you
extract trends from data that you see
okay like it looks like the amount of
data required to train now a 10x larger
model would be this and these laws so
far these extrapolations have helped us
save compute and just get to a better
place in terms of the science of
how should we run these models at scale
how much data how much depth and all
sorts of questions we start asking
extrapolating from a small scale but
then these emergencies sadly that not
everything can be extrapolated from
scale depending on the benchmark and
maybe the harder benchmarks are not so
good for extracting these laws but we
have a variety of benchmarks at least so
i wonder
to which degree
the threshold the phase shift
scale is a function of the benchmark
some some of that some of the science
the scale might be
engineering
benchmarks where that threshold is low
sort of taking
a main benchmark
and reducing it somehow or the essential
difficulties left but the emergent the
scale at which the emergence happens is
lower just for the science aspect of it
versus the actual real world aspect yeah
so luckily we have quite a few
benchmarks some of which are simpler or
maybe they're more like i think people
might call this systems one versus
systems two styles um so
i think what we're not seeing luckily is
that
extrapolations from maybe slightly more
smooth or simpler benchmarks are
translating to the harder harder ones
but that is not to say that this
extrapolation will hit its limits and
when it does
then
how much we scale or how we scale will
sadly be a bit sub-optimal until we find
better loss right um and these laws
again are very empirical laws they're
not like physical laws of models
although i wish
there would be better theory about these
things as well but so far i would say
empirical theory as i call it is way
ahead than
actual theory of machine learning
you